hey this is presh talwalkar
thank you for 100 million views
very few educational channels reach this
level
and many channels with large budgets
from sponsors and crowdfunding have not
reached this level this is a tremendous
accomplishment thank you for subscribing
watching and sharing these videos
so let's celebrate here's a puzzle sent
by karen adapted for the number 100
million
find a sequence of 100 million
consecutive non-prime numbers
that is
every number is composite and not a
single number is a prime number
the same method can be used to find
arbitrarily long sequences of
consecutive non-prime numbers too
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
let's find a sequence of n minus 1
consecutive non-prime numbers
recall that for positive whole numbers n
factorial is the product from n to 1.
now consider the following sequence of n
minus 1 consecutive numbers
the list starts with n factorial plus
two
the next number is n factorial plus
three
the next number is n factorial plus four
and this goes all the way to n factorial
plus n
now the first number n factorial plus
two is divisible by two
that's because n factorial is divisible
by two and two is also divisible by two
then n factorial plus three is divisible
by three for a similar reason
n factorial is divisible by 3 and 3 is
also divisible by 3.
the next number is divisible by 4
and this continues all the way until n
factorial plus n is divisible by n
therefore every single number in this
list is not a prime
we can use this method to find a
sequence of consecutive non-prime
numbers for any value of n which is
amazing
here we set n equal to 100 million and
one to get a list of 100 million
consecutive non-prime numbers
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
please check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either at mind your
decisions or at presh tallwalker